hey 42 here a century ago there were an
estimated 100,000 Tigers in the wild
today there were only 3,200 tigers left
in the world welcome to RIF if cats
don't encounter people by the time
they're 10 weeks old they will always be
scared of them there are more statues of
lions in the world than there are real
lions the first-ever product to have a
barcode was a pack of Wrigley's gum five
percent of cats are allergic to humans
Qatar is the only country that begins
with a cue and Iraq is the only country
that ends with one Reed Hastings was
inspired to start Netflix after racking
up a $40 late fee on a VHS copy of
Apollo 13 due to precipitation for a few
weeks every year k2 is taller than Mount
Everest
the Burmese sneezing monkey sneezes
uncontrollably whenever it rains Charles
Darwin let his children use the original
manuscript of on the Origin of Species
as drawing paper if we had the same
mortality rate now as in 1900 more than
half of the people in the world today
would not be alive in Utah it is illegal
to swear in front of a dead person
Olympic medal winners live almost three
years longer than the rest of us Michael
Phelps has won more Olympic golds than
India Nigeria North Korea Portugal
Taiwan and Thailand combined camel urine
is as thick as syrup the soil in your
back garden is 2 million years old
thanks for the view subscribe for more
you